vous êtes le plus vieil ami de
jean-jaces Goldman j'ai bien retenu la
leçon oui plus vieil même si vous êtes
très jeune très frais on parle de
jeanjac Goldman puis qu'il y a le procès
Goldman le film qui sort actuellement
sur le demi-fère de Jean-Jacques Goldman
et c'est vrai que je Goldman n'a jamais
on a jamais parlé son frère à part une
fois regardez ce qu'il disait c'est
probablement quelqu'un qui a compté
comme tous les gens qui te sont proches
ou qui sont de ta famille parce que tu
essayes de les comprendre parce que tu
vis leur
paradoxe leur myè
et Pierre c'est un
mystère j'étais un peu atypique aussi
dans la famille dans le sens où moi
j'étais politiquement musicien ce dit
j'étais intéressé par les conversations
à table les événements dans le monde
parce que c'était disons la culture
familiale
quoi mais bon j'étais toujours dans une
ligne social traître comme il disait moi
je dirais simplement pe social démocrate
classique c'est la première fois qu'il a
qu' a qu' en avait parlé alors Jean
juste Jean-Jacques Goldman c'est vrai
qu'on on voit il est quand même il il a
pris sa retraite très tôt en fait très
tôt ouis
pourquoi j'ai une
anecdote on était c'est le même que
Daniel moi je reviens de La
Poste pour faire en il il a un sens de
la pron
incroyable c'était avant avant son
succès on a on a créé beaucoup de
chansons ensemble dans sa cave à Verdier
et puis il faisait toujours la la
cuisine donc on est en train de déjeuner
il me disait si Sion album qui était
refusé partout il suffira d'un signe un
jour marche il marchera très bien je
m'entourerai je ferai de la scène je
m'entourerai très vite d'autres d'autres
personnes parce qu'il aimait pas être
tout seul sur scène même quand nous on a
fait des groupes il voulait pasêre
chanteur on a engagé Chris Gibson qui
est devenu Gibson BR après et euh et
puis je prendrai Mar tête très tôt alors
ça c'était un peu la façon de jackques
Brell parce qu'on admiré Jacques Brell
et c'était il il il aimait beaucoup
la la personnalité de Jacques Brell et
en fait à 53 ans il a pris sa retraite
pourquoi il a arrêté les les restos du
cœur
ah
je bah je pense qu'il était un petit peu
usé parce que ça lui prenait moi je
m'étais pas rendu compte mais ça lui
prenait la moitié de l'année il faisaent
tout la distribution les costumes les
dialogues les concerts les
enregistrements répéter avec tout le
monde enfin cétait un travail énorme un
moment il en a un petit peu marre et
puis il y a eu un petit il y a eu un
petit kproco sur une des dernières
chansons avec le clip et on l'a un petit
peu vilipendé
ça donc autant lui quand il quand il dit
oui à un projet il sert on signe pas de
contrat avec poign de ça ouais loyal on
fait etis quand il dit ben non là
j'arrête au revoir et 35 ans de bon
Loyau service quand même ça a rapporté
beaucoup d'argent et voilà il était il
en avait un petit peu marre et il fait
il fait quoi la musique il fait toujours
de la
musique parce que je sais que vous par
exemple vous avez fait vous avez fait
vous allez sortir en mars oui il fait il
fait un album d'inédit de album d'iné
ouais c'est ça parce qu'en mars il y a
un album d'inédit voilà qui va qui va
sortir avec vous c'est vous qui chantez
voilà ouais bizarrement mais euh vous
avz un beau grain de voir hein non mais
en fait en parlant j'ai une voix cassée
parce que j'ai eu beaucoup de problèmes
sur mes cordes vocales j'ai eu plein
plein d'opérations et euh avec l'âge et
quand je je me sens beaucoup mieux à
chanter qu'à parler je je peux monter à
des tonalités ouais des tonalités qu'il
aime pas beaucoup lui parce qu' il
aimait pas sa voix qui montait trop
c'est vrai ah ouais donc ça permet de
faire le lien quand on était en c'était
avant 81 70 18 79 on s'est retrouvé et
comme lui aimait pas chanter et qui se
faisait refuser il suffira d'un signe
par toutes les maisons de disque il m'a
dit bah écoute je vais je vais composer
pour toi et lui ça déjà bien bien
composé il m'a il m'a initié la
composition enfin après j'ai fait tout
un chemin avec lui il m'a donné des
titres et le premier titre qu'il m'a
donné que j'ai enregistré que j'ai en
maquê encore c'est je te
promets après il m'a donné si tu veux
m'essayer parler de ma vie enfin plein
plein d'autres titres je bah comme à
l'époque avec une cassette on allait
voir tous les directeurs artistiques des
maisons de disquees et même lui aussi on
se faisait virer de tout le mond on
s'est fait virer de partout partout
partout donc il m' donné beaucoup
d'autres parce qu'on on maquetttait
beaucoup dans sa dans sa cave avec son
Revox et c'est beaucoup d'autres j'en ai
sélectionné une partie il y en a qui
sont de lui il y en a qui sont de lui et
de moi et il y a une chanson il y a pas
un extrait là que vous avez donné là oui
j'ai apporté c'est quoi c'est quoi le
titre je m'en irai bahz-y ça ça va être
le oui voilà non mais c'est on peut
l'écouter on on peut écouter Jean c'est
quoi alors ça c'est c'est c'est un
inédit jeman Chantou voilà qui m'avait
donné à l'époque et je m'en irai on l'a
pas on
l' moi je l'ai je l'ai dans mon sac mais
on l'a pas on l'a pas vous l'avez donné
bah on me l'a on m'a
dit on va on va
voir
ad
va je laisse sur production touche pas
en PO on va voir c'est va te faire
excuse-moi je te le dis g parce
que je t'aime beaucoup voilà je te le
dis mais moi tu me l'aurais donné à moi
je l'aurais mis la prochaine fois tu me
donnes direct je vais donner mon numéro
là dans dans et en live c'est impossible
en live peut pas faire on peut
pas
allez on a capouco on
aoucoouco musique quand nos yeux se
regarderont comme des
choses quand nous deux seront une
évidence bien close quand nos nudités
nous serons vraiment Archie
commune passeer les années lorsque nos
vies ne feront plus qu'une je m'en irai
et cetera dans mon
équipe
mais tuas un peu la VO
de là je l'ai fait au point du feu sur
l'album ch que tu as été j'étais très
influencé parce que pendant cette
période où on travaillait ensemble dans
dans sa cave studio lui il avait des
années lumières déjà de d'expérience
d'auteur compositeur et moi j'arrivais
alors on s'était séparé moi j'avais
rejoint plein de groupes je m'agitais
sur scène à droite et à gauche parce
qu'en fait je voulais prouver que
jeve avec mes cordes vocales qui étaient
très très abîmés je voulais apprendre à
chanter donc je suis allé chanter en
France à l'étranger tout ça avec des tas
de groupes inconnus j'ai même été au
club méditerranéc dans les villages oua
et puis je suis revenu euh je me sentais
bien chané donc on s'est retrouvé il m'a
dit j'aime bien ta voix et voilà
ça a commencé comme ça on a fait des
trucs ensemble et envoiele-moi c'est pas
possible parce que moi c'est ma
[Rires]
préérenvoyer
ah non Goldman il reste la personnalité
préférée des Français plus de 20 ans
après s'être retiré du milieu de la
chanson c'est un truc de fou il regarde
le JDD le classement chaque année ou pas
le classement des personnalités
préférées des Français ou il s'en fout
total pardon si il s'en fout total du
classement des personnalités préféré des
Français je Goldman non je pense pas ça
lui fait plaisir d'être ça lui fait
plaisir mais je pense qu'il comprend pas
pourquoi puisque il est pas vu donc pas
vu pas pris il comprend pas c'est vrai
cette légende qui dit qu'il appellerait
le JDD en il fapp JDD pour dire
enlevez-moi du classement j'ai pas envie
de pas du tout c'est faux ah oui mais
vra ça il a oui oui il a cette qualité
enfin cette qualité il est très modeste
il fait des des des excès de pessimisme
par exemple à chaque fois même déjà sur
le deuxè bon suff signe enfin signé che
chez CBS grâce à quand même il faut
citer ce monsieur Marc lambroso qui
était déterminant dans la carrière de
Jean-Jacques et il se disait ça va pas
le
2è non le deè ça va pas marcher don de
marche très bien quand la musique est
bonne quand la musique est bonne et puis
le trème et cetera il disait non non bah
c'est toi qui va voir ta chance parce
que non non les gens ont marre du
Goldman et le trème album ça va pas
marcher être chanteur c'est pas
indispensable et il a toujours été comme
ça genre mais mais il le joue pas il
fait pas ça pour faire chic modeste
ordinaire non il n'est que comme ça il
est vraiment comme ça alors non oui dit
d'ord moi je suis fan de Goldman mais
mais ma question qui me tu leupine
depuis le début c'est vous est-ce que
vous avez pris des cours de chant pour
chanter comme ça alors je vais répondre
à cette
question non non mais fout-toi de ma
gueule continue non mais c'était
incroyable parce que je trouve que vous
arrivez à aller sur
sur tu vas de ma gueule je me
suis dit est-ce que c Hanouna a pris des
cours de champ parce que vous avez une
je pense que vous prenez bien la
respiration par le ventre toi tu vas
avoir beaucoup de temps pour aller
prendre des cours de
chant merci Jean et Jean fautevenir nous
voir en mars volontiers ah quand tu veux
en mars je ser encore là tu sa moi je la
saison comme ça je je vous amè le single
alors exactement voilà tu peuxener une
petite dédicace au Jean-Jacques aussi ah
ah ouais ah d'accord je vais lui
demander ça me ferait plaisir je J il
fait un truc un bout de papier comme ça
moi je vais le mettre dans ma je vais le
revendre après sur vint et vous
savez en parlant d'argent ah ça c'est
important pour moi le premier disque
qu'on a fait avec le quand on chantait
le dimanche matin matin dans les églises
on a fait un un disque un peu pourri un
disque de gospel qui était vendu dans
les églises tous les dimanches matins et
il y a peu d'exemplaires moi j'en ai
encore un et j'ai vu que sur internet il
se vend 4000 € il y a des gens qui
l'achètent ah ouais tu vois et c'est un
truc c'est avec ça que tu acheté ton
blouson
[Applaudissements]
toi merci d'avoir été avec nous et il
reviendra nous voir en mars c'est un
amour d' exceptionnel j'adore ce mec et
Jean je t'adore Jean il a l'image de
jean-jaces Goman voyez ou pas il est
voilà te jure et on rigole avec lui il
reprend tout bien voilà j'adore bah tu
veux que je te dis voilà g moi tu viens
quand tu veux ici voilà tu viens tu
viens pas tu